yah welcome to this new game playing at
this low man or young man or whatever no
man when hard to tell with those with
this font could be a little l okay so an
English opening and this line okay let's
let's open it up I'm not such a big fan
of those clothes lines and a3 is
designed to prevent any am Bishop before
and actor from ideas yeah mmm how is
this plate don't remember I think yeah
fish about five I Bishop c5 will it take
the Queen
now maybe try for this kind of natural
setup Bishop to d6 mmm he doesn't react
to that maybe he doesn't need you of
course I thought Bishop c5 but okay
can't play this first it seems maybe can
even go to a d5 and I don't think so
maybe now go here play III next I'm
neglecting my king so I development a
bit this is slightly slightly troubling
yeah this is some fairly standard
looking positioned web like him black
should be all right there how do i
develop now they can I can I afford to
actually I'm sacrifice the Jeep on hard
to believe you but I don't really want
to play move like f3 it looks like
really bad chest f-350 hmm you know he's
got to look c6 anthem yeah but see 685
is also also stupid cannot do that ok
now let's play this than it looks it
really looks bad but look son might be
deceiving I don't know how else to
develop the bishop I mean hey could play
we should be too but he just takes it
it's simply no compensation whatsoever k
black can maybe just take Bishop c6 and
then rock d 898 and consolidate King
fig.7 ah but it's not too attractive can
just stay basically I should maybe I
should have exchanged Queens ready now
this would have been much better okay
not much that can do now yeah really I
thought I thought this would just most
be weakened with the smooth they of
course my liking position is also less
than ideal maybe I can prevent the deep
on from moving I mean no I needs to play
night eh to to really get it rolling
yeah or this one I thought this should
be should be okay
I mean just okay it's not like him White
has some has something here now just
play some slight approvals I don't have
any spectacular idea anyway Jack
maybe the Queen trade I don't know maybe
I can try a bit I mean it's not a
fantastic maybe it is some stone mmm
really okay maybe it is still slightly
annoying for black look give for you
five go be five we could change
everything ok now that I need to try
this it's not it's not to inspiring but
the only way to at least keep something
on the board but should be five Roxy
five minutes it's also draw
mmm is there a go Roxy too yeah I know a
i know it is a draw but I just I want
one one last idea maybe i can get the
King to rook to King situ and I know but
maybe I have to be born let's say let's
try for us for a little bit
hmm
I need to do really am quite a few
strange rules to transfer this to a lost
position but ok rookie six is the threat
what I'll take that sometimes it's good
to play on yeah they're already what's a
little something I mean it's a map look
a two I have to be porn I don't know
this is a GU this is an edge it's not to
draw any more maybe he had to had a easy
draw reform but this is not even without
blundering and suddenly it's not
completely easy I have those then the
only one with ideas and the beep on its
it's a not so space this is something
for what ok thanks for watching